domain and range are by far the most
important concepts and functions and
there is a very high likelihood that you
would see a question based on them what
is a domain in simple words the domain
of a function is a set of all possible
input values and what is the range of a
function the range is a set of all
possible output values the domain is the
set of all values that go into the
function and the range is the values
that come out so if we have a function
like y is equal to f of X the domain
will be all possible values X can take
and the range will be all possible
values for y is there any good way to
remember this how do we remember that
the domain is all possible input values
and the range is all possible output
values may be something like D comes
before R and X comes before Y domain is
X and the range is y okay nice shall we
try out a few examples now the first
function is f of X is equal to X this
function will simply give out the value
it takes as the input instead of saying
it does nothing a better way of saying
it would be the function multiplies the
input by 1 and gives an output anyway
coming to the point what will be the
domain and the range of this function
domain will be all the values X can take
in this function X can take any value
yes just about any value so the domain
is all X and the range which is y or the
output can also take all values that X
takes so the range will be all Y values
here's the second function f of X is
equal to x squared what will be the
domain and the range of this function
try it out
the input X can take any value so the
domain will be all X the range is
interesting will it be all Y it will be
all y greater than or equal to 0 why
because the square of any number cannot
be negative it will always be
non-negative to give you some good news
there are two main constraints that are
very common in the exams look at this
function f of X is 1 over X minus 2 what
is the domain of this function domain is
the set of all possible input values can
X take any value here yes
all but one value the domain will be all
X except X equal to 2 that's the first
constraint the denominator has to be a
non zero cause if it is a zero then the
function will be undefined easy here's
another one what is the domain of this
function can we have a negative number
within the square root well I don't
think we can so X minus 3 will be
greater than or equal to zero this means
X has to be greater or equal to 3 X can
take any value which is greater or equal
to 3 that brings us to the second
constraint even roots can have only
non-negative numbers under them remember
this well the denominator has to be a
non zero and even roots cannot have a
negative number under them now for the
last problem of the session find the
range of this function
by range we mean all possible output
values look at this term can it be
negative know the square of any number
will be greater than or equal to zero so
the minimum value of the function will
be 0 plus 1 which equals 1 f of X will
be greater than or equal to 1 as x
squared will be greater than or equal to
0 so that was all about domain and range
but the most interesting concepts
related to functions are to do with
their graphs we will see those in the
next few sessions
you